thank you
[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts you are going to be playing
Radio City Music on September
I'm I'm doing uh Radio City Music Hall
September 22nd in New York City tech TV
called super maximum retro show that
premieres in March and uh I'm uh I have
a uh a front my butt's in the front I
got surgery to put my butt in the front
last week was packed with
exciting news for all the Christmas
Stefano fans out there in addition to
announcing his biggest show yet at the
legendary Radio City Music Hall in New
York City Chrissy D is also set to
become the host of a brand new show on
Vice TV called the super maximum retro
show which will debut early next week to
share some more about all of his big
announcements it's now my pleasure to
welcome the one and only Chris DiStefano
to our show now during the time of this
interview Chris is on the road in Canada
so our Zoom might freeze at times the
connection might lag a little bit but
who cares we got Chris's Stefano on the
freaking comedy news let's just enjoy it
Chris thank you for being here man thank
you so much uh I I'm in Vancouver
right now so uh it's it's nice it's
really nice if you like fish if you like
the mountains and if you like Asian
women then I would come to Vancouver
beautiful well besides being in
Vancouver right now for a festival I
hear you have some other big news to
share with the comedy World yep I have
um
I'm I'm doing uh Radio City Music Hall
September 22nd in New York City uh my
biggest show ever um you know I started
I'm from New York start a comedy in New
York place called the Maui Taco so
I'm excited to go from the Maui Taco now
to Radio City so Chris D comedy.com for
tickets I have a bunch of other stand
updates Florida I'm in tech TV called
super maximum retro show that premieres
in March and uh I'm uh I have a uh a
front my butt's in the front I got
surgery to put my butt in the front
that's I think that's the big news we
were really looking for the the front
butt
so uh I I'd like to talk about all those
things pretty quickly um Radio City
that's big for you you're from New York
does that mean anything extra being a
kid in New York and now you're getting
to play a legendary venue there yeah it
does because you know a lot of times you
know in these other cities and you know
get to play the theater there or
whatever and like uh it was my it'll be
my first time ever seeing that place but
Radio City I mean I've walked past and
looked at you know hundreds of times in
my life been to shows there
um
and you know when it stands up like when
I made the decision to do it you know
from Queens Brooklyn area and um you
know I remember like just
like thinking like if you're gonna do
this then you have to go do it now like
I went right from the elliptical machine
at Force Fitness and Ridgewood Queens
and I went right to do my first open mic
and I don't know when I put Radio City
on sale it just like brought me back to
that time because a lot of times I'm not
proud of myself I'll just beat the [__]
out of myself or be like you know
whatever thing that may go good in my
life will always create some reason in
my head to be like well that it doesn't
mean as much as you think it does blah
blah blah but for this one I was just
like actually for the first time in my
career just be like you know what just
take this in and be proud of yourself
that you have accomplished this yeah for
sure I saw your reel on Instagram it's
pretty emotional 13 years of work going
into this all leading up to this point
is there an over under for Tears on
September 22nd uh yeah I'm you know I
feel like well I mean my mom's
definitely gonna cry
um I also have uh um a quite a big um
schizophrenic fan base so they'll
probably be uh crying
um for no reason and uh I think I think
um if I see my if I see my dad anywhere
in the uh in the venue if I like make
I'll probably start crying that's
awesome so two more questions before we
go here about the super maximum retro
show
um just overall what's the what's the
premise of the super maximum retro show
the super maximum retro show it's
basically I've done the 19th from the
1970s 80s and 90s things that would like
look back I can't see like the world
used to be
and like how you you know you could take
so much
I froze oh yeah you froze now you're
just unfrozen a little bit did I freeze
again
no well now you're unfrozen hi but yeah
good now I think I think we got the gist
of it and I can I can definitely explain
it more
um in between the clips
um I just have one more question for you
in this new age of comedians making
things independently uh a lot of people
are self-producing things many comedy
fans just assume that any show produced
by a network could be overly PC or a
little watered down so on this show will
you be able to say stuff like Bing Fung
into the Duck Sauce yes I will be I'm
saying things even worse than being Fung
into this on the show actually you know
I gotta get Vice TV credit and Camelot
credit they really let a lot of the
edgier stuff stay in the show and they
fought for it as much as they can so I
respect that yeah so you will this is uh
you know it's on late at night so this
is this is why it's it's it's one of
those things where it's like they kind
of just let us go for it which I I
respect yeah that sounds awesome all
right so we can check that out either
beginning of March I'll figure out an
exact date on that uh it's a topic of
this whole video so I'm sure we know
what the date is by now Krista Stefano
thank you so much for joining us today
here on joke world it was a pleasure
talking to you man thank you my friend
according to this Show's own description
the super maximum retro show is a 30
minute comedic clip show that brings
together a panel of hosts Krista Stefano
and three special guests from the
entertainment industry to comment joke
and make fun of some of the most absurd
things to come out of the 70s 80s and
90s the super maximum retro show will
debut next Tuesday March 7th at 10 pm
Eastern only on Vice TV long time
co-host of the bonfire Dan Soder
announced last week that he's officially
leaving the show with his last episode
alongside Big Jay oakerson happening on
March 1st many comedy fans were deeply
saddened by this news but apparently
it's no big surprise as dancers been
playing with the idea of leaving the
show for over a year now
um March 1st will be my last day on the
show I'm gonna be it was a Band-Aid rip
she has H Christ I told you dude I was
gonna rip it but March 1st is gonna be
my last day on the bonfire however the
bonfire will continue with big J and uh
Bobby Kelly is Robert Kelly Bobby
Kelly's gonna jump in which I can't now
we gotta I did just rip the Band-Aids we
gotta go and talk a lot about it I think
we're gonna have dramatic build up I
don't know I'm bad at this I don't know
I just wanted to throw it up
um it was real climax right away yeah I
just came fast yeah that's all over my
pants but if you weren't listening yet
yeah well I mean they're going to remind
them after every commercial break if
you're back it's
Dan's announcement that he's leaving in
a week in a week two weeks and yeah we
got uh well next week yeah next week
announce every commercial breakage
coming back spawn fire which I will be
leaving oh one commercial break it'll
just be Bobby when you come back hey how
you doing I'm Dan format change hey Dan
I wear wrestling shirts dude there are
only two comedians ever in the running
to replace Dan soder's Big J's partner
apparently the choice came down to
Robert Kelly or Joe DeRosa with Bobby
Kelly eventually being named the newest
member of the bonfire team via Instagram
where he said quote can't wait to take
this crazy ride with big Jay oakerson
and the bonfire crew I'm honored to be
doing such an amazing show I would never
dream of filling dance Outer shoes
because that could never be done but I
will guarantee Jay and I will have a
blast and continue to keep the bonfire
burning guest spots from last week your
mom's house had on Matt Voltron no
Christina P two bears one cave was Tom
and Ryan Holliday kill Tony tonight is
with Brian Moses and Ty Rivera flagrant
had on Johnny Mitchell Kelsey cook was
on the Honeydew with Ryan sickler Andrew
Schultz was on the blocks podcast with
Neil Brennan and Joe DeRosa was on Matt
and Shane's secret podcast where'd you
get that shirt from dude I bought off
the internet all right cardigan you
[__] [__] clear glasses are hard
against dude you better watch Dude cool
socks shut up
you literally look like a [__] you
look like a threat
that's for real
my third grade teacher's outfit
she was a woman
she was a dumb woman do you think she
will slap you on your own couch I'd love
to beat the [__] out of you
this past weekend with theovan was a
solo episode The Joe Rogan Experience
came out with a brand new protect our
Parks featuring shingles Ari shaffir and
Mark Normand whiskey ginger head on
Meghan Trainor the Hardy garbage voice
where I take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman Ralph Barbosa was on the
Chrissy chaos podcast Bobby Lee was on
you know what dude with Robert Kelly and
tigerbelly did not have a guest
as far as new stand-up specials go
They're either coming out soon or
already out Drew Lynch has a new special
out on his YouTube channel right now
called Drew Lynch and these are jokes
that came out three days ago and it
seems pretty good I would definitely
give that a look if you are a comedy fan
also Bert Kreischer Razzle dazzles
coming out on Netflix on March 14th I
saw that show live did a whole recap
video right here on this channel so
check that out if you want to learn more
about what that hour of Comedy is like
Kelsey Cook's new special The Hustler is
set to come out tomorrow February 28th
and Big Jay oakerson has a special
coming out April 5th called dog belly
getting close to that date so fans are
getting excited that special will also
be on YouTube there's so many specials
coming out right now are being announced
to come out later so I'm sure I missed
some please let me know in the comments
what specials I need to be reporting on
next week I'll make sure those get in
there that does it for this episode of
the joke World comedy news update as
always thank you so much for watching
this video and we'll be back again next
Monday with some more comedy news shout
out to Crystal Stefano for joining the
show today that was pretty sweet if you
live near New York City go check them
out September 22nd at Radio City Music
Hall that show should be awesome we did
make some edits to our conversation with
Chris just because the internet was
acting up and stuff so if you want to
check out our full interview with Krista
Stefano they'll be posted on our second
Channel clip World sometime later this
week that's all I got for you guys today
go follow us on Instagram if you're not
a dumb bastard I really hope you enjoyed
this episode you enjoyed the interview
we're gonna get to do more of these
coming soon for you guys so hopefully
we'll have the interviews with the
actual stories we're talking about uh
coming out soon make sure you subscribe
to joke World tap into everything we're
doing right here because we got a bunch
of videos coming out later this week I
hate that I was like tap into what we're
doing but we got a lot of videos coming
out later this week so
um just just get involved dude just
[__] get involved and uh thanks again
Chris thanks again for all of you for
supporting the channel making it
something that Chris and Stefano would
want to come on
thank you to Brian
that's it see you next week
[Music]